well okay today i'll talk about
explainable causal inference
results so we i think a lot of people in
this room are actually doing a lot of
causal inference or inference in general
using all kinds of models and
methodologies
to to come to those results
so i'll try to
well explain a little bit what we
well one of the techniques that we
actually developed or
use
to uh to try to explain inference
results in a high-tech system context
so i'll first give a short introduction
about az so where i'm working
and sketch the context for a moment
after that i'll give a short
introduction to the bayesian bayesian
networks
which we actually use to do
causal inference
after that i'll explain the technology
that we we use to actually explain the
infrared
infirmity results coming out of the
bayesian networks and well i'll end with
a conclusion but well that that's
typically the case
so
first
easy at a glance so ac is a joint
innovation center which which is part of
tno
the mission of az is to embed leading
edge methodologies into the dutch
high-tech systems industry to cope with
the ever increasing complexity of their
products well that's a mouthful
but what we are doing is basically
develop methodologies and well to some
extent prototype tools
to to help
the the high-tech industry in the
netherlands to to well
keep
improve and
innovate
ac started in 2002 and it was actually
integrated in tno at two in 2013 so next
year will turn 20.
it consists of about 55 staff members
most of them have quite a bit of
experience
and of them are five part-time
professors who are also teaching or
involving courses at universities
we
we actually work in industry locations
so all or most of our projects are
together with partner companies and
where well then we basically
go also to the location of the customer
of the partner company to
see what they are doing and try to
really do something that helps them do
their job
so as i said the focus is on
managing the complexity of high tech
systems
through system architect architecting
system reasoning and model driven
engineering which is something we
strongly believe in
by delivering delivering methodologies
that are validated in industrial
practice which is of course related to
the fact that we also work at the
client's place
the direction and the things that are
interested to the to the partners are
well of course established by the
partner board
so we we have quite some uh well
interaction with the partners in order
to determine what is the relevant
research area
we we should head for uh six of them are
industrial partners which are
rather fairly known to most of you i
think
uh five universities and of course tno
itself
so
the context in which we are working
um causal inference can of course be
used in many different places so
healthcare in order to to see whether or
not
you you'll have a disease you could
create models for that to to
have all kinds of data inputs or
measuring inputs
that eventually come up with a
probability that you might have a
certain disease or not
diagnostics is another one that is
mostly used well also very applicable in
high-tech industries so what what if a
system breaks down what could then be
the cause of the system breaking down
what what component might have failed
also in
sociology
there's a lot of causal inference going
on
but
today
you should consider that the context for
me mostly is the diagnostics context in
the high-tech systems
and now i clicked it soon
okay good so um causal inference can be
done in many ways one of the ways or
well the the implementation that we
actually have is
by creating a causal model for a system
or whatever
so you could create a causal model in
the form of a bayesian network
and those bayesian networks are very
nice and very good at what they do
however
they tend to become rather big
and for a lot of you
well a lot of you but maybe also in
general for for a lot of people
the output is is all that matters right
but when we are actually talking to
people about for example diagnostics but
it can also be a disease so
what if
we want to know why
a certain property or probability
becomes high
then what measurements that we did
were actually leading to that conclusion
and that is something that we basically
call the node of interest
so when you have this large network over
here
then what what if one node here is
actually the node that we are interested
in what measurement well what
known nodes observable nodes in the
network are actually
well
relevant to coming to a conclusion at a
certain node so that's what we are
trying to answer here
so first a very short introduction about
bayes nets
a bayesian network is a probabilistic
graph a graphical model that represents
a set of variables and their conditional
dependencies via a directed acyclic
graph
i i guess many of you have worked at
some point with bayesian networks or are
at least familiar with it maybe a couple
of hands for those who are familiar with
it well that's quite a lot
so
i'll go i'll try to be fast here so
this is one example of a bayesian
network it is actually a very classical
example of a bayesian network i think
most of the courses about them will
start with this example
so
what we have here is four different
variables cloudy sprinkler rain and wet
grass each of them can be true or false
or yes or no or depends or how you look
at it
and
for each of them we have a
probability table so a conditional
probability table so in there we just
say that if for the range if it is
cloudy
then there's a 70 chance of also having
rain
30 chance of not having rain of course
because it should sum up to one
if cloud is now what you you see what
i'm going here
we have that for basically every every
variable in our network
and together they form a well a
distribution of all those cpts
so
that is basically what the bayesian
network is
bayesian networks satisfy the local
market property that is relevant for
what i'm about to talk later
um so given the parents of a node the
node is conditionally independent of its
non-descendants so that means that
if
well if we want to know something for
the sprinkler we should basically only
look at the cloudy in this case
because that's its parent
and what is good to know is that the
graphical
or sorry the bayesian network is a
graphical representation of the
factorized joint probability
distribution of the all those cpts
combined so
that is basically expressed over here
so what can we do with it
we can do inference with it so given the
joint probability distribution we can
just try to compute given
these priors on cloudy we can just
compute the probabilities in rain
[Music]
okay
that doesn't sound scary at all
okay
good
so what we can do is based on these two
cpts we can then compute the
or infer the probabilities for ray yes
and no
by using those probabilities right
now click
yeah
we can also insert evidence in the
network most of you will probably know
that so what if we know for sure that
that it is cloudy then of course also
the probability distributions in those
two nodes will be updated we'll simply
simply compute that we can also do that
by inserting evidence at the end
so that if
we know that the grass is dry then it is
well
actually almost undetermined whether it
is cloudy or not
so we can do all sorts of reasoning
using those bayesian networks
so
well a slightly more difficult network
i'll not go into the details of what the
network exactly models because i think
that's not relevant for the story at
this point so just consider that we have
a bunch of nodes with cpts
and we we use this network to reason
so we we have a slightly bigger asian
network here
let's say that the network is partially
observable so we can only
observe the values for those four nodes
in your network
what
if we now would like to reason about
what is stated or what the probability
is in the orange node
so yeah
what four nodes are actually relevant
for reasoning on the orange one
intuitively you might say
that
all the green nodes connected
to the orange node either directly or
indirectly via other gray nodes
might be relevant for it
and that might as well be the case
but
doing it for such a small model is of
course pretty easy
doing it for such a large network
which is not even a that large network
this is about 100 of nodes
so if we have this network then it
becomes a little bit more tricky to to
reason about what variables are relevant
for giving a certain probability
so
what we are using is actually we use the
fact that the bayesian network satisfies
the local markup property
by
defining
a markov blanket
a markov blanket is basically for a node
is basically saying what nodes are
relevant
for to or needed to infer the
probability in a given node so
for for this node a
all the nodes here are relevant for
determining what the probability
distribution and that one will be
that is an
innovation network of course
so
there's just one problem
that
the notes in your markov blanket are not
always observable as you've just seen in
the previous picture
only four nodes in the network that we
have were observable
so
telling me that those four nodes are
relevant well it might tell me something
but it still is not everything of course
because we we are actually looking for
the green notes that are relevant for me
so that's basically what we are trying
to do
and we are trying to do that by
extending the markov blanket
which is basically
recursively
applying the markov blankets for every
node that is not
either observable a root node or a leaf
node
leaf node is typically the end result
but if the leaf node might have parents
you can also of course take the markov
blanket off that leaf node again
so what does that look like
for so we're now about to do that for
for this small model so this is our node
of interest
previously we saw the intuitive approach
where we basically assumed that this one
that one and that one would be
interesting for us
let's now see if
if that also checks out using our
approach
so we start of course with the orange
node
and for this orange node we compute
and include the markov blanket of that
node
then we basically end up with this one
so what we have done is we have taken
the two
parents
and the children's
and the parents of the children's
so well in this case you see that the
parent of this ch child was already
taken because it was also a parent of
that one
uh similar for this one
yeah so that edge is also included this
one is actually measurable
we we observe that value so well we we
can just stop there
sorry i forgot to say something
the blue nodes are the ones that are
newly added to your extended markov
blanket but are not yet end stage so it
is not yet a root node observable node
or leaf node so for the blue ones we
again compute their markov blankets and
include them in the extended markov
blanket well in this case it's pretty
simple because well this one already had
everything in the mark in the extended
mark of blanket and this one well it
just has one child so well that that's
when where it ends
end result
is
that
we have
limited ourselves to those three green
observable nodes in the network that are
apparently relevant for determining this
one not only intuitively but also
mathematically
this this will hold
so just as an illustration this is the
rest of the network that is basically
can be ignored for determining this one
so that is just three out of four
well
let's do it for a bigger one i'll not
give all the details now because that
will uh
take more than the 13 minutes i have
left
um so again we consider all the green
ones to be observable i i really hope
you can also see it in back
and this orange node is the only one
that we are interested in and we would
like to find out what degree nodes are
apparently relevant to determining this
one
so we again start here
we take the markov blanket of this one
and include it
for the blue nodes because one of them
is green so we observe it so we can stop
there
for the blue nose we again take their
mark of blankets
and click
and we repeat this process
all the way
until we eventually
hit all green observable nodes
so
what do we end with it's only a very
small well
fairly small not very small but still a
lot smaller than what we originally had
so what you see now is that only this
part and that part of the graph are
apparently relevant for determining the
probabilities in this one
those are just eight out of the 22
observable nodes that are actually
relevant for this one
which well limits our
search base a bit but what for in our
case for the diagnostics case really
helps is that we only have to
give information to the users about a
certain property in the system
given those eight nodes because the
others are apparently not relevant
so it makes communication a lot simpler
in a way
so
we've now seen it when we have this
observability but now we'll just remove
a little bit of observability to see
what happens if we do that so
we will remove the two
nodes that are now marked
blue so we'll remove those
and we apply the same algorithm
so we again extend
extend
etc
i should have automated this one maybe
so
what you see
is that we eventually end up with
basically the whole network only the
nodes in the in the very end are not
observed but also not included because
there's an observed node in between
so what what do we learn from this is
that
whether or not the extended markov
blanket really helps in identifying the
relevant nodes for your node of interest
it really depends on
one the structure of your network in
this case we have a lot of
cross-dependencies that that might mess
up the network
well the mess up the the creation of the
emb
and two the observability if you
just observe in the beginning and in the
end of course
the
your extended markov blanket will simply
tend to cover the whole graph unless you
have clear branching in between
so
going back to the high-tech systems
what we've observed
applying this method is that a lot of
sensors which are basically your
observables in the system
they tend to be in parallel so you you
normally have the the system flow like
electricity or whatever you you have
some sort of flow and then in parallel
there's a sensor that does not interfere
with with the the normal flow but it
does measure it
so what you'll then see
is
well this is basically the simple
example we had before
but we have this one so instead of
having this one green observable we
actually have something that senses this
one but well the observable nodes is not
on that place
you can probably imagine what would
happen to when you compute the extended
markov blanket in this case
so for this we
we propose a trick
we basically map
those sensor nodes
to the one that is being measured
by that node
and then
just compute
as usual
in this case it's just two steps after
that we map it back
so we we get back to the the original
nodes that we had
and we marked them again
and what you'll end up with is basically
the extended markov blanket that you
also had before
but now with the sensors included in
your network and for example on this
node what you can see
is that if we would not we
would have kept this one gray then we
would probably have extended again on in
this path
and in this part
that's now no longer the case so it is
not really
well let's say
messing up
now it does limit your extended markov
blanket
helping you to identify the relevant
points
so that is basically something that we
we did over the last well it is just one
small thing that we use to make
make the results more explainable to the
to the end user
but we did this
actually using the library
agreement pi agreement which is to be
honest not really a python library
because it's actually implemented in c
plus
with then a python layer on top of it
but we've also considered pymc
which is by the way part of num focus
upon grenade and pgm pi
which are also
probably very good
bayesian network
libraries actually i was surprised by
pymc
the last time i looked at it because
it seems that since we have decided to
go with pi agreement a lot has changed
but so probably should reconsider
at some
point but those are just
a bunch of of libraries that you can use
for for implementing bayesian networks
or this algorithm
because the algorithm only depends on
on the graph structure of the bayesian
network and it does not need any
probabilities actually
you can also just use something like
networkx which we also use
to to do those graphi algorithms
so
to conclude
um
well we use the emb the extended markov
blanket to
to determine the relevant nodes in a
given network for
a node of interest
as i just said it can be applied on the
graph structure alone
given that of course the graph structure
represents a bayesian network because it
is still based on the fact that you
should have a local markov property in
place
and yeah well
that's basically it
we applied it in an industrial use case
and
in there we saw for a network of roughly
6000 nodes
of which just 250 were observable the
extended markov blanket
basically limits the set of sensors
relevant to the average nodes to just
25. which is a reduction of well 90
percent of the nodes
which really makes it a lot easier to
explain to people why
the probability in a given node is as
such
so
thank you for your attention of course i
would also like to thank my colleagues
at az
if you have any questions feel free to
either reach out to me or
ask questions now
[Applause]
thank you for your question um i was
wondering uh so
specific to the use case industry uh
what was the motivation to use this uh
yeah methodology because there are of
course i mean some golden standards
they're like karma filter
like early after second world war two
that it has been used i mean
researchers from different disciplines
use it a lot and it's quite explainable
however this methodology that used is
already coming from healthcare so it's a
sort of methodology developed in a
healthcare domain and now you're trying
it to try to extend it to industrial
setting so how could you comment on this
uh
yeah well
uh good question
uh i think partly it's uh it has a
historical reason for for just doing
this um
part of it is because we can just apply
it on the grass structure which is which
just makes it very easy for us to limit
and very easy to compute
[Music]
yeah
i think it is just this this is what we
know we we applied this technique and it
seems to work
and it really helps a lot and because of
that we just stick with that method but
if there are any other
methods to do basically the same thing
or
something similar then i would be
interested to hear about those
so at some point you
explained a different technique by
basically mapping the green ones on the
gray ones right
don't you lose a lot of accuracy if you
do that
since you make the model basically way
less complex and maybe you miss some
important information um
now well we are not changing the model
uh so so all we do is um temporarily
restrict
the search space for the bayesian
network just to limit it at the place
where we actually have the measured
thing so so
you should
consider that
when you have a flow of things or well
that's really vague if you just have a
sequence of uh of components let's say
and at one moment you you measure
something
then
what we now do is just consider that the
thing that is being measured we just
secretly say that is observable
we consider that observable because
there's a sensor well actually that
sensor is not really in the flow of that
system so it's not really in this in the
chain
so that's all we do
and that just limits the
[Music]
definition of the extended markov
blanket but it does not
influence any computation at all right
all right
uh thanks a lot for that
for the presentation um one question i
had wasn't the topic of the of sort of
the time component to this because i
imagine that
some
impacts of the
of your nodes can also be impacted like
three hours beforehand for example yeah
um
looking at the cloud sprinkler rain
example if it was rainy an hour ago uh
wet grass is still true even though
currently might not be cloudy anymore
how do you tackle that yeah that's a
known limitation for bayesian networks
bayesian networks
tend to just be able to reason at one
instance of a time except for when you
go to uh
to dynamic bayesian networks where you
basically have multiple instantiations
of your bayesian networks uh which in
which the variables are linked together
so they they basically have some
relation
but in this case the the network only
uh
represents a single point in time
um yeah
currently we we apply that thing well
that network we can do several
computations through time but you you'll
miss that relation until of course you
go to the dynamic bayesian networks but
at this moment we don't do that
simply because the networks will get
huge if you do
that got it thanks
thanks i i had a quick question as well
which is
um could you extend this or maybe have a
simple heuristic where
you can decide to place a new sensor on
like you know if you have all these gray
notes like can you pick the one where it
would most limit
for most you know things that you care
about how big your
extended mark off blanket ends up being
that that would be possible to do if you
if you would decide on
on a set of metrics
okay yeah
we don't currently do
that hi uh could you maybe comment on
the complexity of the algorithm like
what is the time scale to generate this
to to
to create the extended marketplace yes
yeah
it basically just has to walk through
all the nodes in your network
um and by simply caching i mean once you
have decided on your observable set
you can simply cache the the extended
markov blanket for each node and when
you hit the certain node you can
basically just append
the extended marker blanket of that node
to whatever you already have
so in that sense i would say
well you'll just have to block a couple
of times through your network so it's
not that complex
thank you
could you hold it a bit closer sorry
invasion networks where there's more
reliance on creativity as opposed to
measuring things like in physics so this
is often happens in things like
sociology where people just assume this
is probably the joint distribution
are there any kind of gothu things that
you have to be aware of if you use this
technique because there is no way of
knowing what the physics would say about
the droid distribution between two nodes
uh i'm not completely sure whether i get
the question
okay so markov model uh sorry a vision
distribution basic model
but where the joint distribution between
the nodes can never be really known
like in sociology
yeah in that case you you might
that's not what we do but you might
consider trying to learn a bayesian
network of course
by basically looking at sensor data and
trying to derive a model from that
but at this moment that's not what we do
because we create the models from
from design documents etc
so suppose i have a factory with
like a bunch of gray notes basically
places that i could measure potentially
and i only know the the orange one so is
there would you would you know a way to
kind of find the minimal number of
places to put
green nodes to measure the orange one
yeah i think that relates to the
question that was posed there uh so
indeed i think you could try to develop
a method that given a note of interest
would
determine
what what nodes need to be measured and
by repeating that for a lot of
nodes that might be interesting for you
you could eventually come up with an
optimal set of green nodes
well
i think
really
proving that it's optimal would be
impossible
but at least coming to some sort of
consensus might be possible
yes so uh i was wondering so you have a
let's say if you have a large network
and you're interested in a particular
node and you start to draw these
blankets
at some point it may become really big
yeah so
and but on the other hand
you might
suspect that you say well something that
happens on the other side of the world
cannot be so important
for what i'm looking for here
so are you also considering something
like perturbation theory
let's say approaches where you say well
things that are very far away
i can somehow maybe ignore or neglect
and of course there are counter examples
where you can always show that it is not
allowed but i would say for real life
problems
it should be possible to do some kind of
approximations yeah currently we don't
do that but it's indeed an interesting
idea
but it greatly depends on the use case
you're looking at indeed
you